i mean it just what i've realized from
writing this book about mental health is
that humans we're really not that
complicated we like to think of
ourselves as these magical mysterious
things we're just complicated plants we
need light we need water
we need oxygen we're very connected to
nature and our you know our thoughts and
feelings and emotions
they don't come from this ephemeral
place where we have no control over how
we think and feel
they're just brains reacting to signals
from our bodies you know anxiety
is just our body trying to protect
ourselves from a dangerous situation
and yet how it manifests in our modern
brains is this
weird you know terror about a social
situation you can't quite put your
finger on but when you break it down
and go hey wait a minute mental health
isn't this thing that controls my life
that i was born with it's like actually
we're all just people and machines and
bodies and biological things and
we can just do things that change how we
think and feel and for me as someone
that has really just
struggled a lot of my life with mental
health thinking i'm just broken
i was built that way sometimes i just
feel bad and there's nothing i can do
about it that's wrong
there's something you can do you know
it's easier that's kind of like the
throwaway way to say it's easier to sort
of blame
a disease um yeah but it's like
i understand that sometimes you're stuck
in a cage and like you need things like
antidepressants and therapy and things
like that and like to kind of help you
out
free but to get to a place where you
recognize that
you are in control of this and that
the mind is kind of like the secondary
passenger
and you need to retrain it i mean it's
it's a lot of times i've done a lot of
this stuff too with
different aspects not necessarily
depression or anxiety but
other aspects of my life of patterns
that would show up
and i ended up realizing holy crap this
is
my six-year-old self
yeah those profound therapy moments
you're like i'm not that cliche damn it
i am that cliche i'm stuck in that
walmart
my fifth birthday party it's a human
experience and this is
like a lot of people they have this idea
that mental health is just for people
that have crippling anxiety or people
that are like suicidally depressed and
they have a medical problem but
mental health is just how you think and
feel at any given moment and it's
something that all humans have
so people go i don't need therapy i
don't need to read a book about mental
health because i'm fine and it's like
yeah but how stressed are you how much
do you worry in a day what is your
mindset
that completely controls your outlook on
the world from how you perform in your
career
how you deal with your relationships and
most importantly
on a day-to-day level how do you talk
back to the own voice in your head
because for me you know my experiences
in life i went through a lot of bullying
when i was a child i had a very
upsetting time for the first 18 years it
built me to be this very cynical
defensive person
and my first instinct the first voice
that would pop up was always that
self-sabotage
self-doubt and that's not the truth and
what's so important
is being able to stop like look in the
reflection of what's really going on and
think
is this the truth or actually am i kind
of sabotaging myself
in this way and it's something that
every single human on earth goes through
but most people go through their entire
lives
without questioning it yeah i feel like
people might be hearing and especially
if someone is kind of stuck in that spot
where they're like no
no no like this is a disease i'll have
this forever
and this is just something i have to
deal with or
something like um
you don't get it it's a lot worse for me
right i can imagine if someone is
listening that isn't able to hear
how much accountability they can and
should be taking for their life
they might be thinking you don't have it
as bad as i do so i think it's
probably uh important to
explain and unpack like what depression
looked like for you for someone to go
oh he was there definitely i can i was
like
maybe i can do this exactly and
that was me i just i i felt like some
days i would wake up
and i would be in this like deep
depression i'd be like i don't want to
do anything from the live face down on
the floor and i would tell myself
this is just a bad day it's a write-off
like the whole day is gone
and unfortunately that's not true
because there is always something
you can choose to do to change your
environment your way of thinking
what you're doing why they can snap you
out of it and
i don't resent myself for that because
that kind of procrastination of going
like this is too hard to deal with
it comes out of a place of fear which is
completely understandable because it's
it's terrible if you if you have
awful anxiety if you are really stressed
if you are
seriously depressed maybe you're
grieving or something like that it's
horrible to go through
so of course you want to tell yourself
like i'm i just want to give up and i
just want to be defeated
and so many people are at different
points and everything helps so for some
people they
need the medication to give them that
strong foundation
so they can then make changes to their
lifestyle because some and this was this
is me you know i've been on
antidepressants and there was a period
of my life where
you know i couldn't snap myself out of
it or readjust my mindset or change
my lifestyle to be better for my mental
health i couldn't get out of bed i
needed the antidepressants to stabilize
my mood
there were points where i couldn't have
these conversations with myself because
i didn't have
the self-awareness or the perspective to
realize how toxic
my self-perception was until i spoke to
a therapist and she was like
boy you're crazy this is uh you know
what you're saying right now it's not
true you are you you just have this
awful perspective of yourself and not
only is it making you sad but it's
stopping you from growing as a person
because you're just holding yourself
back out of fear and you can't stay
trapped there
so for so many different people this is
the thing there's all the knowledge out
there
and when it comes to mental health
there's so much misunderstanding it's
like is it a medication thing
is it a therapy thing is it just a you
know knowledge and
lifestyle changes and it's like it can
be all of that we're all built
differently
you have to see what works for you but
the most important thing is you can't
just let life go by
without trying to make it better because
when you make that change
and you become healthier and happier
everything in your life just multiplies